il est l'heure de la question du jour on
parle de politique constante vers notre
gauche pour se poser cette question le
Parti socialiste peut-il disparaître
c'est simple vous votez oui ou non sur
le Figaro.fr et puis nous on en parle
avec ce feedravinel bonjour Sophie
bonjour bonjour
la réponse de nos lecteurs concernant le
Parti socialiste alors vous savez quoi
on n'a pas encore cliqué pour savoir ce
qu'on pense nos internautes on les
laisse 80 % 80% mais vous avez vu la
réponse non j'attends j'attends bon euh
ce parti socialiste vous suivez de
presque qui s'y passe depuis plusieurs
jours on commence par les derniers
éléments ce lundi enfin une rencontre
qu'il a demandé écoutez c'est une
rencontre je crois qu'ils étaient tous
volontaires pour essayer de de se mettre
d'accord ou pour essayer de trouver un
accommodement Pierre Le Pelletier qui
suit les questions socialistes
particulièrement là ces derniers jours
dans la crise la partie sur place et
effectivement
j'allais dire surprise ou pas surprise
ils n'ont absolument pas réussi à se
mettre d'accord on reste donc sur le
drama qui dure depuis désormais le
premier tour de ce congrès qui n'est pas
parvenu à séparer Nicolas meilleur
Rossignol donc celui qui vient essayer
de mère socialiste de Rouen qui vient
essayer de battre Olivier fort donc un
premier secrétaire sortant du Parti
socialiste
et les deux qui sont arrivés donc en
tête devant Hélène Geoffroy la troisième
actrice de cette pièce de théâtre
terrible mère de Vaulx-en-Velin ancienne
ministre et bien les deux sont sortis
avec un eau c'est à dire aucun accord
entre les deux alors aucun accord je dis
absolument est-ce qu'il y a ce soir un
premier secrétaire du PS non toujours
pas toujours pas parce qu'il y a deux
personnalités qui prétendent l'une comme
l'autre vouloir diriger ce parti alors
les personnalités d'accord mais est-ce
que la direction du Parti socialiste la
commission
certains ont tranché en disant en ce
moment alors on se parle Olivier fort et
Nicolas Mercier secret une commission de
récoltement qui a travaillé jusque
jusque 60% des résultats
c'était ce weekend sur la base de ces
résultats Olivier fort puisque la
réunion a tourné court pour des
histoires
d'embrouillamini compliqué à expliquer
mais de fait Olivier Faure a décidé de
d'avancer qu'il était donc premier
secrétaire avec 20% de d'avance et
Nicolas meilleur Rossignol conteste
affirmant qu'il y a triche et que cette
triche ne permet pas d'affirmer encore
ce soir qui est premier secrétaire
et ce week-end il y a eu discussions
commissions pour essayer de régler ceci
sauf qu'on analysé que 60% des
fédérations c'est bien ça absolument
mais alors comment on peut être certain
que l'un des deux pourquoi cette
commission n'est pas allé au bout ou
parce que il suffit selon les proches de
Olivier Ford de dire voilà que l'avant
c'est suffisante et que la la le fait de
persévérer de la part de Nicolas Meyer
Rossignol n'est plus tenable parce que
il faut savoir quand même et nos
lecteurs-ligneurs peut-être mais le
Congrès se tient ce week-end à Marseille
et donc dans quelques jours dans moins
de cinq jours et donc là il faut qu'il y
ait un vainqueur il est absolument
impossible d'imaginer c'est pourtant ce
qui est en train de se dessiner cette
commission s'est arrêté à 60% des
dépouillement des des fédérations
qui ont quitté la table sur des
désaccords portant sur la façon
d'analyser déjà ses 60%, il y a en fait
et moi je discutais avec Emmanuel Morel
qui est un député européen socialiste
ex-socialiste pardon c'est très
important et là quitté le parti
socialiste il y a quelques années pour
rejoindre l'environnement de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon même s'il ne l'a jamais
rejoint totalement et il me disait mais
enfin ces histoires de triche c'est
totalement hallucinant moi ça fait 25
ans que je suis là il y en a toujours eu
de la triche et tout dépendait à quel
degré et lui qui était minoritaire
européenne a toujours vu la minorité la
majorité
s'octroyer plus de voix pour asseoir se
notamment l'UMP et le problème le drame
c'est que aujourd'hui c'est parti
d'ailleurs aussi bien l'UMP LR que le PS
qui ont été des parties qui ont dirigé
la France
aujourd'hui ils sont réduits à portion
congrue et il ne reste plus chez eux que
cette triche qui surnage que ces
inimités personnelles on voit avec
l'organigramme pléthorique à droite on
le voit à gauche avec cette guerre des
chefs il ne reste plus que ça et ce qui
est ça qui est dramatique c'est c'est
l'effondrement idéologique de ces
parties le Parti socialiste peut-il
disparaître vous dites oui vous dites
non on découvre dans quelques instants
votre réponse Sophie on a commencé
analysé ce qu'il s'est passé est-ce que
en 3 minutes on peut remonter le fil
ensemble de ce qu'il s'est passé il y a
une élection et trois grandes candidats
qui étaient ces candidats au-delà de
leur nom qui les soutenaient c'est ça
qui m'a alors il y a il y avait la ligne
majoritaire historiquement majoritaire
celle d'Olivier fort puisqu'il a déjà
été réélu à la tête du PS après avoir
été élu et donc cette ligne majoritaire
c'est celle qui a construit et lancé
soutenu l'accord de la nupes qui a donc
précédé les législatives et qui a permis
sinon d'accroître sinon au moins de
maintenir les forces de la gauche sur
les circonscriptions en France il y a
ensuite Hélène Geoffroy son opposante
historique elle aussi qui est de la
ligne L de François Hollande ancien
président chef de l'État elle a été son
sa ministre secrétaire d'État et elle
est mère de vous enveloppe elle a
pratiqué et elle pratique encore l'union
de la gauche dans sa ville donc il faut
le savoir mais elle est très opposée
aux accords avec la gauche radicale et
avec les insoumis en particulier
Jean-Luc Mélenchon au milieu et on n'a
jamais trop réussi à savoir quel était
son pourcentage d'opposition ou 100
pourcentage de soutien Nicolas Mayer
rossignol qui lui est le candidat d'Anne
Hidalgo Anne Hidalgo donc ancienne
candidate des socialistes à la
présidentielle 1,75% je vous le rappelle
à la présidentielle au premier tour
dixième sur 12 absolument contre
28% pour François Hollande au premier
tour de 2012 donc en disant donc il y a
trois candidats premier tour serré parce
que fort est à deux doigts de l'emporter
donc il fait
49,8 % ou 7 %. un petit un score assez
confortable quand même qui lui déjà sur
le est-ce qu'il était élu au premier
tour il fallait 51% quand même
mais de fait c'est l'alliance de Nicolas
Meyer Rossignol et d'Hélène Geoffroy qui
a mis Olivier Faure en difficulté alors
même que les proches de Livier fort nous
disaient avant le premier tour ça va
être peut-être un petit peu plus tendu
qu'on ne s'attendait mais il n'y a aucun
doute sur l'issue en fait il y a eu des
doutes finalement deuxième tour c'est
jeudi dernier jour de manifestation à la
gauche est réunie alors déjà étonnant
pourquoi c'est un jeudi c'est toujours
comme ça c'est historiquement les
élections au PS se déroulent le jeudi se
déroule en fin de journée et se déroule
localement dans des urnes c'est ça qui
est très intéressant ce n'est pas un
vote électronique c'est un vote sur
place et c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de contestations il y a eu des
votes dans des appartements dans des
boissons
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce
qu'on sait ce qui s'est vraiment passé
moi j'ai eu passé des vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux et je les ai vu circuler
avec des personnes qui cachent des urnes
dans des pièces fermées d'autres qui
crient mais dans un sens comme dans
l'autre il y a eu de la triche partout
et comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure il n'y a plus que la triche pour
remonter parce qu'il n'y a plus comme
par exemple avant le congrès de Rennes
où il y avait aussi des désaccords
congrès de reine de 1990 où il y avait
des désaccords historiques entre toutes
les lignes à l'époque mais il faut
savoir que c'était l'époque où François
Mitterrand règne encore en maître et où
il y avait évidemment des forces
idéologiques importantes des vrais
figures le Parti socialiste comme les
autres parties encore étaient des lieux
de formation
n'était plus que des ce n'était pas
seulement des lieux d'expression
d'ambition personnelle un peu médiocre
comme aujourd'hui hélas et donc c'est
ces dissensions à l'époque
était très forte mais elle s'était
réglée sur en sortant par le haut d'une
certaine manière aujourd'hui
on peine à savoir ce qui distingue et
fort et Nicolas Mayer rossignols sur le
fond et en d'autres temps il serait
évidemment sans doute dans un même
courant
en plus j'ai vu 27000 votants absolument
contre par exemple 2008
ce fameux souterrain
135000 à l'époque et c'est complètement
impressionnant et sans doute encore
qu'après il y en avait eu d'autres
d'autres congrès avec encore plus de
votants
et donc c'est ça qui qui c'est cette
pauvre c'est cet appauvrissement
qui rend l'affaire aussi piteuse
et qui ne va sans doute pas rapprocher
les Français de leur dans leur affection
ou désaffections des partis politiques
le Parti socialiste peut-il disparaître
oui non je vous pose la question très
clairement dans un instant Sophie je
sais que c'est toujours difficile mais
vous avez suivi de près avec Pierre
Lepeletier du service politique du
Figaro vous qui suivez la gauche ce
qu'il s'est passé ces derniers jours ce
que selon vous selon votre conviction
personnelle de ce que vous entendez
est-ce qu'il y a eu de la triche oui
bien sûr il y avait de la triche des
deux côtés des deux côtés comment
trancher alors est-ce que ça peut en
justice tout ça ça peut partir en
justice mais qu'est-ce que la justice
peut trancher dans des affaires internes
on a vu avec la fameuse coco et si ça
vous dit quelque chose je m'en souviens
voilà les histoires c'était la droite et
c'était des grandes
les grandes heures de cette droite poste
Sarkozy et
c'est on voit bien que la justice n'a
pas été au parti moi j'allais dire c'est
toujours
il peut y avoir des recours en justice
il y en a eu un on connaît dans
l'histoire de notre vie politique
française des recours en justice
est-ce que c'est ce qui va se passer
mais ça prendra du temps et que pour
accomplir la justice et qu'est-ce
qu'elle pourra aller chercher sur le
terrain alors que bon certes il y avait
des huissiers il y a eu des constats il
y a eu des mais je pense qu'il faudrait
que ça sorte de façon
raisonnable par la volonté de l'un ou de
l'autre alors Olivier Faure a fait des
tentatives ces dernières heures il a
proposé éventuellement à Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol de prendre le lead sur les
européennes qui sont les prochaines
grandes élections de 2024 il a il y a
alors je crois qu'il y a une proposition
de co-présidence mais qui a été refusé
par Olivier Faure l'un comme l'autre
avec Hélène Geoffroy qui tente me dit-on
au milieu d'apaiser les deux parties qui
qui jouent un peu le casque bleu ou le
casque blanc et qui me dit-on encore ne
met pas du tout d'huile chaude sur le
feu ou d'huile tout court d'ailleurs
mais enfin on se demande bien quel
médiation pourrait permettre de sortir
de cette impasse ce soir le Parti
socialiste peut-il disparaître oui ou
non Sophie Ravinel le fameux sondage moi
je voudrais bien savoir j'ai parié 80%
pour dire pour oui
au vu de nos chers lecteurs du Figaro je
pense que moi je dis oui alors
91,48% de nos internautes pensent que
oui le Parti socialiste peut disparaître
alors justement c'est quoi le stalinien
si je peux me permettre quels sont les
options maintenant un parti coupé en
deux et bien non parce qu'il y a un
grisbi et donc selon la célèbre réplique
ne touchez pas au grisby et bien il y a
de l'argent il y a encore beaucoup
d'argent on a l'impression que le Parti
socialiste est tombé à rien après la
présidentielle parce que 1,7% quand même
c'est moins de 5%, c'est donc pas de
remboursement mais en fait si il reste
le siège déjà du PS en banlieue
parisienne il reste aussi il faut le
savoir 19 millions d'euros dans les
fédérations qui sont les ancrages locaux
du PS avec dans tous les coins de France
des bâtiments aussi et donc un gros
budget
il faut mettre la main sur le Grizzly
mais il ne faut pas partir sans le grés
de vie parce qu'il y a aussi n'oublions
pas 5 millions de dotations publiques du
fait des parlementaires attendez vous
êtes en train de me dire que c'est
l'argent qui va tenir le Parti
socialiste et forger son unité l'argent
peut avoir ce mérite celui de l'unité
pourquoi pas Mayer Rossignol il est pas
anti nups
c'est pas tout à fait clair sa position
c'est pour ça on n'a pas une vraie
opposition d'idées là on n'est pas sur
de gauche je dirais considérer
totalement c'est plus des questions
auxquelles vous faites allusion selon
les mots de Manuel Valls ancien Premier
ministre donc c'était plutôt justement
la France insoumise et le PS au sein du
PS comme je vous le fait
de l'ifort ça c'est peut-être non
il faut savoir qu'elle a une Geoffroy
elle a dans sa dans sa vie une gauche
qui est très
mélenchoniste et elle est tout à fait
capable de faire maire de vous en
voulant absolument elle est parfaitement
en mesure de ces associations c'est
disons une priorité d'alliance pour les
législatives mais aussi pour les
européennes elle ne veut surtout pas je
crois que ce qu'il est distingue c'est
le refus très fort chez Hélène Geoffroy
de voir le PS se couler dans cette nupes
qui est selon les voeux des insoumis qui
devraient pourrait se transformer en une
seule formation c'est bien ça ma
question le pastis socialiste ou cette
forme peut-il disparaître vous me dites
qu'il va pas être qu'il n'y aura pas de
session parce qu'il y a de l'argent mais
est-ce que cette gauche sociale
universaliste laïque peut vivre dans ce
parti socialiste là qui semble suivre
les pas de la France insoumise sans
doute pas pourraient-ils y avoir une
émergence d'une autre formation
qui espèrerait récupérer une partie de
ceux qui sont partis chez Emmanuel
Macron mais je ne voudrais pas les
décevoir j'en discutais cet après-midi
avec un politologue professeur
d'université Rémi Lefebvre que je
recommande beaucoup à vos micros parce
qu'il est très intéressant sur la gauche
et bien lui il me disait que cette
gauche partie sociale démocrate parties
chez Emmanuel Macron est aussi cette
gauche qui était avec
François Hollande devenu assez libéral
et qu'elle est désormais très acquise
aux idées libérales d'Emmanuel Macron et
qu'elle pourrait sans doute
difficilement revenir vers le Parti
socialiste merci beaucoup Sophie
draminet dernière question François
Hollande s'en est mêler il a pris la
parole
jamais abandonné et lui soutient très
fort Hélène Jouffroy il est très opposé
très engagé contre la nupaisse version
alliance insoumise et il reste passionné
très attentif à tout ce qui se passe
merci Sophie Davina merci au service
politique du Figaro en charge de la
gauche et grâce à vous pour mieux
répondre à cette question du jour le
Parti socialiste peut-il disparaître la
suite du programme point de vue c'est à
18h Vincent roux on parle de la semaine
à haut risque pour le gouvernement sur
la question de la réforme des retraites
évidemment et puis à 20h le Club
International c'est Philippe jelly qui
vous reçoit et qui vous parle avec ses
invités des relations parfois difficiles
dans le couple franco-allemand je suis
sûr que vous allez regarder Sophie
excellente soirée